A source of light we tend to take for
granted and not really think about
as a light source is the sky.
Especially for outdoor environments,
a lot of the ambient lighting
is actually sky lighting.
So let's enable it in this scene.
As you can see,
the shadows gets a nice blue touch here.
Let's disable the sun in order
to isolate the sky lighting.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Areas where more of the sky is secluded,
like under the roof in the back of
the scene, is getting generally darker.
But it's a very smooth effect that
also accentuates details and geometry.
The most trivial example of the
importance of the sky as a light source
is a cloudy day.
Just like in the middle of the night,
the sun is not reaching in, but on
the cloudy day, it's not dark outside,
because of the light from the sky.
It should be said that the light from
the sky is mainly light from the sun
taking a different path down, but we
won't cover the details surrounded here.
For most application you
want to treat the sun and
the sky as two different
light contributions.
Sky lighting is a very effective way
of setting the mood in an environment.
We can experiment with different
colors and it makes a big difference
[BLANK_AUDIO]
In this case, we're only looking
at constant color skies, but for
more realism, it's possible to use
images representing the actual sky color
from different directions.
Unfortunately computing proper sky
lighting in interactive applications can
be hard from performance point of view.
Different flavors of ambient ablution
can take you part of the way though.
This wraps up the sky lighting session.
Thanks for your attention.